hey youtubers is Charlie a lot of you
guys have been asking me about where
spider-man homecoming fits in the Marvel
timeline so this is gonna be a complete
breakdown of all the Marvel phase 3
movies and where they fit in the
continuity there is a new round of the
spider-man giveaway that starts now all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video be sure to click that bell to
enable alerts so you don't miss anything
during the break so the cool thing they
did is they cut the spider-man teaser in
the homecoming trailer at least the
International trailer in a way that
allowed you to contextualize it with the
end of Civil War like this is when he
gets the suit this is when he's in Civil
War doing all this stuff
this is him getting dropped back off in
his neighborhood getting ready to start
his sophomore year of high school so
spider-man homecoming will make it
really easy to judge the Marvel timeline
usually you can kind of guess when the
movies taking place in the movies
themselves move in real time so ant-man
happens right after the events of age of
Ultron but they're kind of changing that
a little bit because there's gonna be
three movies a year really soon so it
gets a little confusing and then you
have movies like Doctor Strange that
have to do origin story stuff so they
flashback so they jump around in time a
little bit so here's an explanation for
the timeline where spider-man homecoming
fits into the events of all of the phase
three movies
the only wild cards on this are Black
Panther and Captain Marvel because those
are so far off those will probably do
the same thing the Doctor Strange tit
where they flash back then they pick up
in present day but the very first Marvel
phase 3 movie is Captain America Civil
War the problem is is that it's not the
beginning of the phase 3 timeline
because technically that's Doctor
Strange so the end of Doctor Strange in
the end of Captain America Civil War
sync up in the timeline but the
beginning of Doctor Strange when he's
still just a doctor before he has his
accident is after Winter Soldier and
potentially after age of Ultron because
the Avengers tower exists but before
Captain America Civil War so a lot of
you are asking what was the deal with
that Winter Soldier shout out Kevin
Feige clarified that the only reason
that Hydra considered him a threat and
had him on their list was because of his
extreme aptitude as a doctor they didn't
know anything about him becoming a
future sorcerer supreme so he was a
threat
just because he was super smart and then
you know just because it's hard to guess
where it falls relative to age of Ultron
even after they built the new Avengers
facility the Avengers tower still exists
in New York City they just don't use it
as a base of operations anymore so when
we see spider-man homecoming if he goes
to Manhattan we'll probably see the
Avengers tower in the skyline then you
have the first part of Captain America
Civil War where Tony goes to Queens
recruits spider-man and then sends him
to this hotel where he gets the new suit
what the hell is that what the hell are
you wearing
we should where's the case okay so you
see the case then he fights in the
airport battle scene then Tony takes him
back to his neighborhood says he can
keep the suit and you have like the
duration of this trailer here all the
events of the spider-man homecoming
movie it gets to keep the suit of course
doesn't fit me just don't do anything I
would do and definitely don't do
anything I wouldn't do there's a little
gray area in there and that's where you
operate but this does not mean you're an
Avenger okay so we're wondering then
that movie basically goes from the fall
of this year to the spring of next year
he's a sophomore in high school so the
film itself will take place over like a
six month period or so but they do
flashback in time to when he's wearing
the old school hoodie suit before he
gets the stark tech suit so they will
jump around in time just like they did
in Doctor Strange but then around the
same time you have Thor meeting with dr.
strange to try and find Odin so that
supposedly takes place within about six
months of the end of Doctor Strange he's
wearing the gloves
he's been the caretaker of the New York
sanctum for at least a couple months so
will happen is is when you pick up at
the beginning of Thor Ragnarok that
movie will take place like right after
this moments happening here at the end
of the Doctor Strange movie which is
also somewhere right around the
beginning of spider-man homecoming so
you have all these different movies that
all converge at different points but
then the end of Bragg nirach in Black
Panther both lead into the first
infinity war film you also have
guardians of the galaxy
doing the same thing too so until we get
a little more information we have to
assume that thor ragnarok
and guardians of the galaxy and black
panther are all occurring at the exact
same time those movies will end around
the same time and then very shortly
after that the events of infinity war
pick up and even though there's always a
bunch of post-credits teasers that set
up stuff like the big Avengers films
what they'll probably do is they'll
probably use Thor Ragnarok
Tootie's infinity were the most just
because there's so much stano's infinity
gem stuff going on in that in the thing
about guardians of the galaxy two is
that there's no Thanos and no infinity
stone James Gunn already confirmed so we
arrived at the first big benchmark
infinity War part 1 what happens after
that
so they used to have like part 1 part 2
so they just said that they're gonna
name the second Avengers film something
completely different because there are
two completely different films so the
first big film after infinity war is
gonna be ant-man in the wasp that's
gonna be where the new wasp costume is
supposed to debut Evangeline Lilly said
that they had opted to just hold off on
it so that they wouldn't be taking
something away like a big reveal away
from their own franchise so like ant-man
the wasps great characters is gonna be a
lot of fun but just like Doctor Strange
was a slightly weirder smaller movie
than say like a big Avengers team-up
ant-man and the wasp will have a lot of
that same energy that you saw in the
first film just like a great sense of
humor a really weird story that can be
self-contained but also connected to the
other films but here's the thing though
infinity war is going to fundamentally
change the Marvel Universe
all the characters the relationships to
say nothing of what the multiverse looks
like like if Thanos tries to destroy it
with the snap of his fingers like he did
in the comics then who knows what's
gonna happen even if they're able to fix
it things won't just go back to normal
so also picking up in the wake of
infinity war is the Captain Marvel movie
so it sounds like what's gonna happen is
is that even though Captain Marvel's
being released after ant-man and the
wasp both of those movies will be
happening concurrently picking up right
after infinity war because Captain
Marvel is sort of getting the spider-man
treatment in infinity war where she has
like a brief appearance but it's really
huge she probably gets her powers via
soul gem and then they sort of deal with
the ramifications
Asians of that in the Captain Marvel
movie just like they're dealing with
spider-man in spider-man homecoming even
though we've already seen him in the
stark tech suit in Captain America's
Civil War so Captain Marvel gets her
fully fledged story we learn all about
her then after that movie the next one
is the second untitled Avengers film now
with that we'll probably be is something
like all-new all-different Avengers
where they just shuffle the roster bring
some people in bring some people out so
that's really sort of the end of phase 3
they might tack on some extra films at
the end of that depending on the
performance of some of the phase 3
movies they're all doing really well so
far but they've just eased that phase 4
is gonna look radically different so the
timeline of those movies is totally up
in the air but what you'll see like they
kind of tease this is that you see a lot
more crossovers like Thor Ragnarok is
sort of a Planet Hulk movie it's like a
buddy roadtrip movie you'll see more
team up style movies like that instead
of seeing like Iron Man 4 you might just
see Iron Man team up with another
character like Doctor Strange so it just
allows them to have some fun with the
characters in a way that they might not
have been able to do with the standalone
films in phase 1 and phase 2 the suit
Peter
forget the flying monster guy
there are people who handle this sort of
thing so no matter what I promise you if
you need us if you need me
[Music]
I'll be there so let me know if you guys
have any more questions about the Marvel
phase 3 timeline when all these films
are taking place when they begin where
spider-man fits into all of this but for
the most part up to now they've all
moved in real time the exception to that
is when they flash back for brief scenes
like when they're doing origin stories
or when they're doing something totally
different like guardians of the galaxy
like James Gunn has even gone as far to
joke that they're in a different
universe like the guardians are totally
removed from everything that's going on
in the main Marvel films I haven't had
to worry about continuity or anything
like that
so really the connective tissue at that
point is the post-credits scenes like
that's what they use to sort of link
everything up so don't worry when you go
see guardians of the galaxy
next spring there will probably be a
Thor post-credit scene that will explain
how the guardians are related to the
Marvel Universe just because they're
both space based franchises and you'll
get a little teaser for infinity war and
then during the earth-based Avengers
films you get post-credit teasers for
everything that will eventually link up
to infinity war so they tend to group
the earth-based Avengers movies together
when it comes to teasing other movies
they've thus far kept the space-based
movies sort of self-contained to
themselves - like the end of Thor the
dark world teased the first guardians of
the galaxy movie so the probably just
continued to do the same thing so what's
gonna happen next is I'm going to post a
Star Wars ob1 video then I'll do a new
video about arrow in the return of a
really big character then there'll be
Star Wars rogue one Easter eggs so be
sure and go see the movie if you haven't
seen it yet I've already posted my
non-spoilery review so I'll be sure to
link that at the end of this what you
guys wait for that to post you can click
here for my non-spoilery rogue 1 review
and you can click here to re-watch those
spider-man trailers thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you